Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
November 21st, 2060 what's going on? How,
why, how's it going? Oh,
I'm doing good man. I hope you guys
would do all, it's a holiday weekend.
Dooby dooby do in school to lead Bop.
You only have to work three days
unless you boss is a fucking cunt.
There's always other ones too are if your
fucking self employed or if you're not
happy with your home life, you'll
come up with a reason. Right.
To go back into work just
to fucking avoid it. Um,
yeah. You know what this
year, cause uh, you know,
we can get in the fucking kitchen done.
We don't have time to cook or anything.
So we're actually going to a friend's
house for Thanksgiving, which is,
which is great because they
live in the same city as us,
so we don't have to go to the
fucking airport right now.
All these fucking people waddling around,
you know,
those people just oblivious of other, you
know, it's a great fucking human being.
Just totally being all about yourself.
Oblivious moment is when fucking people,
you know,
there's a whole herd of people just
riding down an escalator and people like
this second,
they step off it.
They don't keep walking and get
the fuck out of the way. They just,
they're just all fucking
oblivious. It's like, ugh.
You would just on the escalator,
there's 50 people in front of you.
100 people behind your touchdown.
Sorry, I got the game on.
What a fucking throat.
What the fuck is going on with
the package this year, man,
I don't fucking get it. Um, anyways,
sorry about the screaming then. You know,
you got 50 people in front of, you got
a hundred fucking people behind you.
You know,
and people are getting off that kind of
meander in and you're on the escalator
thinking cow, go get out of the way before
we all fall down on each other. Right.
If for any sort of a thinking human being
going like, oh, assessing the problem.
Well when in fucking eight
seconds when I become that person,
I'm going to get the fuck out of the way.
So whoever the fuck is 20 people behind
me will not be having this panic moment
because of me going to become
part of part of the solution.
Not The fucking problem.
Right.
I don't even know what I'm
talking about at this point.
I can't remember the point I was trying
to make, but what I know what I'm saying.
Yeah. That the kind of fucking people like
you know was the top. So thanksgiving.
That's right. Right. So we're going to
fucking pee. I have no idea why point is,
you know what I mean?
I just said a bunch of shit out.
Hope it was funny cause God knows there
was no point and I think that actually
is the point of the Monday morning podcast
for all you people out there who you
know who tend to take it
unbelievably seriously.
Those of you out there who think that
I influenced the fucking election isn't
that hilarious.
$7 billion was spent to get Trump and
all these fucking people a chance to get
elected. But you know that all
goes out the window. The second,
some fuckhead who can't
even read out loud,
does a podcast all out the window.
I'll tell you if that's true.
I'm going to start, I'm going to start
charging more for my fucking advertising.
You know what I mean? Maybe I'll use
that as a selling point in 2017. Uh,
evidently I was, I was the reason Trump
got into fucking office. Oh, Jesus.
Hey, Trump's support. Is he liking
what you're seeing so far? Uh,
you like in these fucking,
you know,
you thought Trump was old
looking at the fucking people.
He's surrounded himself with Jesus Christ.
If they're not an a Nazi fucking movie,
they're like 450 fucking years old.
Rudy Giuliani.
This is like when some old hair metal
band gets back together again thinking
they're going to put out a fucking
relevant album. You're not, it's over.
You had your time. It's fucking
done. You know what I mean?
These guys are going to get the fucking
band back together and start singing
about what, uh, girls in a
strip club and the devil,
maybe the PMRC or whatever the fuck
people used to sing about back in the day.
I don't pretend to know. Um, you know,
we were fucked either way. All
these fucking people, by the way,
I gotta give a shout out to somebody.
Um,
what's her name from
cosmopolitan magazines.
Laura Beck calling out SNL for
the horse. Shit that, that was,
that was that opening completely
agreed when they were singing.
The woman who plays a Clinton,
Hillary Clinton played ilet Luhya and
it was kind of confusing. Like is,
was this a true tribute to fucking,
uh, Leonard Cohen Dying? Or what,
what's this a political fucking statement?
And uh, she kind of called them out.
Go and did you guys have Trump as a
fucking house while he was running for
president? And Al of a sudden, you know,
you help promote the guide then. Yeah.
I mean, shit, if I did by trashing
both fucking people, right?
She actually said it was bullshit. It
was fucking hilarious. It's a great read.
I'll give you guys a, uh, a link
to it, but I mean it's a TV show.
That's what they do.
They did that to a buddy of mine.
They did that to fucking Dane Cook.
They had them fucking a hosted twice.
He made him a bunch of fucking money with
high ratings and then all of a sudden
there's a little blip on the
fucking Internet, you know,
tide turns a little bit and then they
use them as a fucking cheap joke when he
wasn't even a, he wasn't even on the
shelf. That's what they do over there.
That's what they do in this business.
Then at your fucking friends. See,
that's why you know what you do. You stay
where I stay right in my little cave.
You do a podcast by yourself and
then no one can hurt you. Um,
anyways, um, so I, uh,
every time I do a standup special,
you know,
and ends up being a little bit too long,
at least the last couple of ones.
So you start thinking,
what if you take this out here when,
if you do a little fucking thing here and
we have to do, and he ended up fucking,
the whole thing of what you really have to
do is you, you just got it. You
got to cut off a limb. You know,
you've got to remove a kidney. Basically.
You just got to take out a chunk.
And I figured out what chunk
it was going to be or I had an,
an idea that that's what I wanted. And
then the director Jay had the same idea.
We took it out and it flows and it
went from a too long of a special.
Now it's like fucking perfect.
And now we're going to, uh,
and all I've seen at this point
is just the raw feed of it.
So it's not even like an HD
and it looks way over lit.
And then my fucking
pasty God damn Whitehead,
I look like an asshole and it
still looks like a good special.
So I'm very excited. I got that
done. F is for family. Second season,
we're starting to fucking,
you know,
tighten these things down for
the final fucking edit. And, um,
and then next month I'm going to start,
uh,
the process of which should be a quick
editor is editing the audio from what I
did, Madison Square Garden a year ago
for the New York comedy festival. Sorry,
hiccups, New York comedy festival.
I didn't almost get emotional,
the New York comedy festival.
Um,
and then if once I get, I get all that
shit done right then I'm just like done.
I'm done. I can just enjoy
the rest of the fucking year.
I got nothing to do really.
Right. And then, uh,
then it starts all over again in January,
you know,
be nice if I did cardio for the
rest of the week and just, you know,
then I can fucking throw down.
That's another good thing about going
to somebody's place for the holidays.
They got to clean up. You know, you
don't leave with a bunch of fucking food.
It's going to be good.
Um,
I'm excited about when he wants
me to make this fucking stuff.
And I knew she wouldn't let me
just go over there. It's like,
why can't I just be the 12 pack guy?
You know,
that's the best guy you put on a
sweater. Right? He go over there,
you make people fucking laugh to show
up with like a 12 or fucking whatever,
whatever the fuck you want.
You know,
I try this IPA lately and
I'm really not an IPA guy.
I go in and out of that shit.
I usually drink,
just drink shit that's considered
a white trash beer. And um,
cause I just like getting fucked up.
You know, I'm going to do the taste.
I just want to get fucked up. Right. And
I want you guys to say, well those IPA is,
have a fucking high alcohol content.
I don't give a shit. They're fucking,
they're heavy.
Fucking heavy as hell.
But I tried this one, it was called the
Green Line and I got it. I don't even,
because they only had a
couple beers at this place,
was this goofy fucking place and I
just wanted a beer. And they were,
that's one of the only ones they had.
I actually really liked it
and mind me living in Boston,
fucking going up to fuck and
Chestnut Hill and the gray line dote,
Kenmore Square,
go to the fucking sucks rich
Fisk. Um, Gary Allen said,
oh Jesus says a couple of red sox names
from way back in the day. Anyways, um,
I tried that shit.
I actually really liked it and uh,
I don't even want to did guys,
I'm just fucking talking in
circles cause I haven't been home.
I haven't been to my house and like
fucking two months and uh, I've had it,
me and Nia had been living on top
of each other and uh, you know,
I don't know about her,
but I'm,
I'm pretty sick of us being
this close to one another.
So hopefully Tuesday we get back
in the fucking place. Oh, nice.
Fucking throw Aaron Rogers over
the top DB complain and say it,
he fucking pushed off course.
You're going to say that.
That's what you say when a guy
fucking what a tight end beach.
You that deep as a fucking corner.
How the hell does that happen?
How do you let that happen?
I asked you guys,
he pushed him within five yards.
I think that was all right. Um,
anyways, how about those Bruins?
Huh? He handled in Winnipeg.
I was all nervous day that top two
scorers in the league. What did we tell?
We'd put fucking three of them. Three
goals in the second period, right?
Who scored fucking mash and fucking Burgee
Belsky whatever the fuck his name is.
And then, I don't know fuck suites.
We actually went up for nothing. One,
four to one.
That's another thing when I get back,
I got my Bruins and Celtics package.
I can start watching that shit so I can
really start boring you guys with the
sports talk.
You know,
I didn't see the Patriots game today
cause I've been running around and haven't
been spending time with my wife.
So I took her out someplace today.
She'll come on later and tell
you all about it. And um,
but all he knows,
it's the usual shit on my fucking
friends who are pats fans like, dude,
why'd we trade Chandler George?
Why we get rid of Jamie Collins.
I fucking defense stank
stone. Um, so I think it was,
you know what should have been an
easy game, I guess. Evidently wasn't,
but a, I didn't see any of that.
I watched the boxing though.
Who the fuck that Russian guy,
that ego Larry are enough.
Was that his fucking name?
Whoever was a real hacky
Russian name was Sergei Kovalev,
which is like every Russian
guy in the NHL. He's either,
his first name is Sergei
or his last name is called.
That's really like the John
Smith of Russian names.
So he's fighting this American dude.
So I got to go for the
fucking American and uh,
I got to tell you something the
fucking first, first fucking round.
All right.
Ego Iron off comes out and he
fucking punches Andre Reed.
Was that the guy's name? Was that the guy
in the bills? I can't fucking remember.
I'm not a big boxing fan. I
love the sport. I love it.
But uh, it's been ruined.
It's been ruined because every three
pounds is a new weight class that has yet
another fucking champion.
And then there's like 15 different
fucking boxing federations.
It's a shit show like this, more boxing
divisions than there are podcasts.
And I'll tell you that stayed
some, cause there's a lot of, um,
you know what I mean? When I was a kid,
it was like, it was like fly weight.
It was like fly wade,
featherweight, middleweight
welterweight, heavyweight, something
like dad, I can't remember.
I can't remember the fucking
divisions now. Even things like,
there's like 15 off shoots of each
one of them. It's, you know what,
it's like those superhero movies,
like back in the day,
like Superman was in a superman movie.
Batman was in a bat.
They didn't fucking know each other.
They weren't all hanging out at the same
place. Maybe on the, the super friends,
they were super friends. They did at the
hall of Justice. But they only did that.
They did that when they drew it,
but they never had that in movies.
You know what I mean? Superman
was Christopher Reeves.
That was his fucking shit.
And uh, see Batman. Right.
Okay.
Oh, they have. They had Michael Keaton,
remember that he was all sweaty in the
locker room with just a towel around him
where the bat mask and he got in the
face of val Kilmer and he was like,
that's right. Ice Man. I am
dangerous. And then Val said,
clicked his fucking teeth together and
then they all played volleyball, you know?
And then they were playing volleyball.
Aqua man didn't come out of the
Ocean Daddy. You know what I mean?
Looking at Batman being like,
take my breath away, dude.
Who Do you know Kelly McGillis
gets in an invisible jet?
I can't remember the fucking,
I believe the fucking names.
I remember from that movie.
I saw that movie a bunch of times.
That was the one that I owned on VHS.
Winnick Danke Danke [inaudible] right.
I was in high school and everybody
wouldn't want him to get a fucking Ninja
motorcycle and fucking flight
have sixteens, you know, inverted.
We also be, we're going to do that.
You know this, every once in a while,
like a movie comes out and you're like,
you know what?
I'm going to fucking do that.
Right. And then what happens?
You know what happens to geometry,
Algebra two and trig. All of that happens.
So then you're like, oh, I'll wait
a minute. Wait, I thought, oh,
thought I think I was going to fly jets.
Is that what I thought was
going to happen? Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm going to be a salesman.
You know I make people laugh. You know
I, you know, am I coming over room?
I make people feel good. You got
a product? I'll do it. Huh? Well,
you second cutting potatoes like this.
What if you had that?
I liked the guy with the John Riggins
fucking Jersey in the crowd at the
Redskins game, man. 44 it was
always a bad ass fucking number.
That was always a full back number
when I was growing up. John Riggins,
Robert Newhouse, you know Chuck Foreman?
Yeah, I think it was a running back.
Was he 44 that was a bad ass
fucking number. Reggie Jackson.
You know, now you're this guy,
Starks. He's got to live. That's it.
That's a fucking legendary number.
I want to have any fucking
hall of famers were 44.
I fucked debt. How many fucking,
just like skirts were 44. Not a lot.
Everybody have a war. 44 was
a tough motherfucker. Right.
I like to thank John
Riggins broke my heart man.
Cause that was a big time cowboys fan
back then. Um, before,
how about them cowboys and they kicked
out Tom Landry and Tex Schramm. Uh,
that was just the worst.
You know,
I thought Tom Landry was going to be
this forever. You know, I was young.
I didn't know. I didn't know people get
old and it passes him by fucked up. Right.
And uh,
I hated the fucking red skins for beating
the cowboys so much that when they
were in that Superbowl actually rooted
for the dolphins and I hated the fucking
dolphins because we can never beat him.
And uh,
when Riggins broke through the line
and whoever the fuck that was on the
dolphins that came by and just
grabbed him by the waist in slid down,
I'm like a greased fucking pole. And he
just kept running. That dad killed me.
Was it age eight Dewey?
And I'll fucking remember anyways.
Um, how much time have I done? He
was a time for the fucking region.
I don't think so. Um, hey, Neha,
you want to come in here and
tell people about your day?
I get to tell you this shit,
right? So I haven't been, you know,
I've been fucking busting my ass.
You know,
I was getting ready to do this special
and then editing all that bullshit I
talked about earlier. So, you know, if
you don't spend time with your wife,
all of a sudden your wife gets
all upset with you. Like, oh,
you don't spend time with me and
boo Hoo Hoo. I have fucking needs.
Hey Nia, I'm just, I'm doing a character.
What the fuck did I do with the Mike?
There's the microphone. Is the microphone.
All right. Hello. Talk to
me. Talk to me goose. Hello.
Um, so anyways, yeah, I
haven't been spending time
with you. So I figured today,
you know what, I gotta go, I gotta
do something, I gotta do something.
So I took my wife to go see Casap
blanket today while the Patriots were on.
I got to get credit
for that. Okay. So, um,
I thought it was at this old theater
I was telling you about these guys on,
I think Thursday I was telling
him about it. Like there was,
it was all these old theaters out here
then I'm obsessed with where they had the
Oscars throughout the years. I just
think of all the great, you know,
Comedians and actors and directors
and everything that had been on.
And I love that sense of history,
right? So you've got the pantageous,
he got the fucking who, some of what's
out in Santa Monica, the Kodak Theater,
all these fucking places. So, um,
I just remember that one from
the 80s and I always saw,
I guess it was in downtown La.
Maybe that's the one down the other way.
I don't fucking know. But I just looked
him up and I was like, you know what,
I'd love to do maybe a show
there or I might want to do, um,
you know, just go to something. And I, I
looked up that one downtown and it said,
uh,
there was just a bunch of orchestras
there and then it said it was Casablanca.
I'm like a fucking love Humphrey Bogart.
I'll take needed to go see that shit.
So we go down and of course we show
up in the theater. I want to go into,
there's nobody there.
They're like, oh yeah. Yeah,
it's not here. It's at the theater
next door. There's a little old couple.
So you go up and um, we're walking
around the theater. It's completely
deserted. Amari starting to
course fucking storm. Yeah.
Bill's already getting hot.
I'm going to fuck that. I was on the
fucking website. It looked it up.
I looked it up twice.
Couple who are walking with their
little bonnets on because it was raining
outside. Yup. Bill Ass. Like, oh, is
this where they're having the movie?
I was a little more frantic than that.
Yeah.
Like you got you guys coming from the
movie. You're old. And that was my energy
[inaudible] across the
street at the concert hall.
And you had your,
one of your classic but you,
you,
you made the mistake and so you
started having a little meltdown.
I didn't make a mistake because if you
look the fucking theater up and you look
okay, and it says it was at the
Dorothy Chandler pavilion. No,
you click on calendar events and then
it just, it lists and it lists that.
But I think the same person owns the
theater. It's very fucking, you know,
it's like buying a car.
Yeah, we got it this lot.
And all of a sudden you're down the
street. It's like you're in good fellas.
They're a little further down. I Dunno
Jimmy. I think I'll pick it up tomorrow.
That's what they did to me.
Well anyway,
it was across the street at the Walt
Disney concert at the symphony looking
thing that looks like a fucking exploded
golf course designed by Frank Gehry.
It's like one of the most like impressive
the drummer from extreme, isn't it? No,
it's a very famous architect.
Zack,
go lock what you see here.
Get the fuck out. Get the
fuck out. Get the fuck out.
Get the fuck out. What are you singing?
We won't try to, it's one of the widest,
trying to be funky songs
ever. Get the funk out. That
one. And then there's the uh,
some big John is my name.
Anyway, this building,
this building was one of the most like
impressive piece of architecture in Los
Angeles. It's a beautifully designed
space and bill is just like,
I couldn't help but laugh at you because
you were just muttering and cursing and
stomping around in the rain.
Oh, go to this one. Oh, wanted
to go into the gray ones.
Super Modern Shit. I've done shows in
those stupid symphony fucking things.
You feel like you're in front of like
the council and one of those superman
movies where you're like down there all
fucking up above you in that behind you.
I fucking hate those things.
So it was like,
I don't want to fucking go into
this thing. So I end up showing,
but it's like I got to take it to
this thing. It's fucking raining out.
So Nia is all like, whoa,
good. Go to the theater.
Another time when it said Jan event,
so I calm you down cause it's not what?
We're going to another building.
No big deal. You know we're going
to go seek. And then what happened
going, we shout. So we show
up and I go, Hey, can I get,
and I literally said to you,
go, now we're going to fucking go to
this stupid ass fucking theater, right?
It's probably in some small room.
It's going to be be you,
me and four other old people and the
movies, the movies almost ready to start,
right?
So we fucking show up and I
go up to the booth and I go,
yeah, I need two tickets to
Casablanca. And the person's like,
I don't know if there's any tickets left.
And I'm like,
what are you talking about?
It's raining. It's Sunday.
Football's on his fucking movies like 80
years old. Who is going to come through
check, right? And then she finally goes,
well you can't, I should. We found too,
and I'm like, thank Christ,
trying to do some romantic here.
It's not the right fucking theater now
they're going to be sold out. She goes,
you got to go down to windows.
So I say, fine. I kept my
cool, they're there, right?
The rain and rain enough on my steam
and head that I walked over and it cools
you off a little bit. Cool me off a
little bit. And I walk on my goal,
let me get to, and I, they go, okay.
And then they go and the guy goes, okay,
that's going to be $161 I go $161 he goes,
each and we both were like,
wait.
So it turned out no way. So this
is what it turns. It turns out,
I think this is way too loud here.
I got to turn this down here.
It turns out that,
um,
what was happening was the La Philharmonic
was going to be playing the film
score while you watched the movie.
Turns out this is a major la cultural
event that was basically the fall out.
Bill was just going to be a
movie for a few old people in us.
It turns out it's this major event.
Every he's got on like sport coats
and fucking dresses and shit.
I'm sitting there,
my wet hoodie going on,
Humphrey Bogart in there. What
the fuck's going on? Right.
We can view the view the body,
Aaron Eckhart and like introduces
the fucking movie. So you know,
you know when you just don't give a shit,
I just said fuck it.
So I light up the card and I go,
let's go in there.
And then I start getting this
feeling of like, this might be my,
this might be fucking amazing.
And then there's all these ushers walking
around hitting these things that are
gone. Boom, boom. Like letting people
know that, you know, that whole,
like you don't want to
disturb rich white people,
that the things are about ready to start,
whatever that fucking instrument is
called. Um, and they fucking go in there.
Uh, we go in there and, and
like, it's like Holy Shit.
Like we're going to listen to what
the La Philharmonic while we watched
Casablanca and I'll fucking great was,
it was amazing.
It was such an awesome experience.
So bill kind of fumbled,
fumbled his way into her.
Really amazing romantic
day and I get no credit.
I get no credit because I picked
the wrong fucking theater.
I just totally stumped. So
Kenny, you'd be like, Hey,
you see that with the orchestra?
I picked that out on purpose.
I
feel like you definitely get points
for you seeing that you saw something
cultural going on and you're, oh, that
sounds cool. Like Nini would like that.
And we went and it turned
out to be amazing. So it was,
it was great. Yeah. Erin,
it was Carl Marriner was not a hail Mary,
the actor,
the actor came out and
introduced the movie oil man.
Is there another famous Aaron Eckhart?
I don't know. Are you being sarcastic?
I'm being a Dick Right now. Was he in,
was he in no, no country for old men.
He was in then get out of here.
Bitch in the company of men.
And he was in Sally. Sally. Oh
yeah, the mustache. Yes. He was
in that movie. He was in that
movie, which, well that was a movie.
That was a movie they made up.
They made a,
evidently they made up all of this other
shit. It was just so fucking boring.
Can I just say that? You don't
have to say it. I'll say, come on.
It's Clint Eastwood.
It was wrapped up forward Senate.
Jerry's in it has a
bunch of us. We had, yes,
we have friends that are in that movie,
but thou are we a Hollywood
couple of our friends are in it.
That movie was so boring
because you know why?
Because nobody, this is some sounds
so terrible, but nobody died.
Nobody got no, he nailed
her leg. It was nailed it.
He put it right where it was
supposed to put it. Yeah.
There was no hype off by engines.
Went out at 1500 feet.
Should I try to land it in the water or
fly back over the most densely populated
area in the United States, so he put
it in the water. Everyone survived.
The whole thing took in real life,
24 minutes for everyone to get rescued.
It's like, what is the movie about? Well,
they had to have them have to do you
to have the evil corporate guys going.
You couldn't save the jet.
Yeah.
Could you push some people out on the
way over? It just wasn't exciting.
Tom Hanks is, is a, is a wonderful
actor. All the acting was great in it.
I want to see it play a serial killer.
I'm so sick of him always being doing
the right thing. That's not his brand.
That's not Tom Hanks is brand.
He's not a serial killer.
Did he die in saving private Ryan?
Spoiler alert number.
He was just sitting there firing at the
tech. You never saw that? No, it's not.
I'm not into those kind of, I'm not.
It's a war movies. It's not a war movie.
Saving Private Ryan is not about a
war and soldiers that dye in it. Well,
I mean that's literally what it is,
but it's more of a metaphor.
It is saving private Ryan is a
metaphor. Metaphor. What is it?
A metaphor for a,
please explain.
So you don't even know what you're talking
about. Even know what a metaphor is.
It's an incredible fucking movie
and I believe you. All right.
Okay.
We kind of just killed your credibility
to say Sally's boring and then you're
like, yeah, I'm not in a war
movie. That was private. Ryan.
Ryan's almost unbelievable fucking
moves ever saw. Why is that?
Kill my credibility. Just because
I didn't like I said, oh, I see.
That's how it works. One thing has
to do with the other. I don't know.
You've been bugging me lately.
Why? Yeah, I dunno. I just,
I don't want to be a dick,
but he putting on weight.
Excuse me.
You're like putting on weight every
fucking Monte getting bigger and I keep
telling you to fucking do something
about it. I have a condition.
You have a condition. Where
is a commission? Me Bigger
and bigger every month.
I wouldn't have enough.
Okay.
Yeah, the laugh factory
fucking tweeted that out,
so I guess we got us announce it.
Yeah, I'm going to be a fucking right.
Wait gotta be parents,
everybody.
I'm so excited for us. Do you know
what it is? They don't give a shit.
I'm actually,
I think people have been people who have,
you know who you are.
We already tweeted a offline stay offline.
Don't become that person.
I feel like people care. Listen. Why?
Cause it's going to bring out all the
people who have nasty things to say about
it. No, because people have lives. But
people have been actually been very sweet.
What,
what
no,
you know is you're watching those fucking,
those lady screaming at each other too
much and the ones where they sit around,
you know, it was one of the funny
things I saw lately. It was when you,
you had the fucking Kardashians
on what the sound down? Yeah.
So much of the footage as them just
looking at each other with their fucking
mouth kind of open like slack
jawed because someone else
is talking over the top.
Just going, I just feel like when
Mandy said to sandy that she, you know,
she couldn't go during the nose job trip.
I felt that she was upset and we,
as the person's talking, they just cut to
their faces. They're like, dude, I can't,
it's official.
They look like those little pouty cats.
Okay. Let me know. Okay, what the heck.
I don't know what that had to do.
I don't know.
I just want you to turn this
into a Kelly rip a moment guys.
And this is what were just
makes me feel like, you know,
I'm starting to understand why
Michael Strahan left that show.
Um, so anyways, yeah, it's official.
It is confirmed. All right.
No it is and I'm,
and I'm just going,
I'm not going to one of
these fucking assholes.
You're very, no, you're like,
you're grudgingly talking about
it and I understand why. I know,
cause I fucking hate parents.
You hate math. I hate it. Why?
[inaudible] is just the
hardest fucking job,
the most rewarding job. Like
Blah, blah blah. And you know,
and then they all say it,
they all fuck.
Even like chuck Yeager would
say some shit like that.
It's like really dude flying
a fucking jet up into space.
Like trying to get a kids fucking
backpack on for first grade is,
is more difficult than what the
fuck he just went through up there.
You know what I mean?
I think that they placate to fucking
isn't the right word to Joe Sixpack where
they gotta be
little heroes, panda, panda. They're real
people are the real heroes out there.
The people out there,
they're there. They're,
they're baking the tuna fish sandwiches,
cutting it into four fucking pieces.
You had sex and you didn't use
protection. That's what you did. Now here,
you're right.
You're not Tom Hanks pretending to
land a fucking into the Hudson river.
Okay. You did. It's not exactly
the miracle on the Hudson.
So all Billy booze bag's going to get a
couple more rights and lefts in before
the little, the little one comes. And then
I'm going to be, I gotta be, I gotta be,
so I've got to pick my spots.
Is that,
is that the idea is that's what's been
happening that you've just got to go on
like a little bit of a bender.
The,
I've been on a bender the whole fucking
year and then when the baby comes,
you're going to just like cut yourself
off. Yeah. I mean, what am I doing?
Maybe fucking hung over and we'll
be that guy. No, I hope not.
Yeah. No, I'm not going to do
that. Now that's over. It's done.
But then I got all this great hooch back
at the house, so I got, I got us kill it,
kill it before it comes. You have to like
drink all the alcohol before the baby.
It's not like you're
never going to happen.
Do I gotta make space for like fucking
sippy cups and shit though? Not Word.
A word. A wordle suck in my bottles
down. They're not going to go on the bar.
You don't have to worry about
making sport. You know what?
I'll save some of my pappy van winkles.
We had more than most spoiled kid ever.
When the baby's teething, I'll
rub pappy van winkles on. It's on.
It's fucking gums. Isn't that what
you're supposed to do? I Dunno.
I Dunno. I like that.
That's an old school thing,
but I'm already going to do this shit.
Like every time the kid cries,
I'm not fucking going in the,
I'm going to,
there's this great book that I read
on Norwegian parenting that says that,
you know, when the kid starts crying,
he just, it just kind of, you know,
you creep up to the bed and then
you kind of look and he just go hi
and then that's it.
You scare the shit out of it and
it understands what's going on.
You're making fun of, when I told
you was in the book that I'm reading,
by the way, it's 29 24 fucking Washington
Bay just score. This is a great kid.
This might just be one of those
old San Diego Charger Games.
Are you watching the football game
while you're doing the podcast? I Dunno.
I just thought that's not a push in the
back. Get the fuck out of here. Anyways.
What were we talking about?
Oh, you're having a kid.
I'm probably the biggest moment in our
relationship ever. Nobody did. Well,
let's see what happens.
Yeah,
so we've been going to like
fucking lamaze classes and shit.
She's fucking Christ.
The classes have been great.
The classes have been
great, but this, this,
this is how far the fucking
progressive left has gone,
is a fucking line for when she comes in.
It says, mom, will you sign up in me?
I'm thinking finally name of mother,
name of mother and then I'm like,
and then my column like I'm finally going
to be called a dad after almost living
on this planet for half a fucking
century and it just says partner
fucking ridiculous.
And what kills me is everybody
in their heterosexual,
all in a fucking relationship.
Everybody there was was there was all
straight couples, straight couples in.
All the dads were there.
Yeah, yeah, that's true. And
then she just keeps going.
Coaches, coaches, calling them
coach. I swear to God, Dude,
I'm to show up with a
fucking whistle next week.
No fucking bill Bellacheck Hoodie and
shipped the fuck are you talking about?
She said she probably, she's probably
going to get in trouble. She said Dad's.
Why his last class?
I didn't hear it too busy muttering under
your breath about every time she says
coaches,
I say fathers or fathers.
I'm not trying to cut out gay people
or people who got bag behind a fucking
Carl's Jr. You know what
I mean? But what about us?
That's the solution. I
thought it's inclusive. He's
supposed to include people.
I'll take second and third billing
behind a alternative people.
What did you think of that?
I'm birthing video that we
watched the last glass. Oh,
Paulie's a placenta.
That was tremendous.
I don't know.
I don't even know why I'm there near.
It's all going to go
out the fucking window.
The doctors and nurses are
going to tell you what to do.
I'm just there for your fucking
yell at me. It's so fucking stupid.
If I was going through
gallbladder surgery or whatever,
you would not be in there holding
my fucking hand. It's so dumb.
This is just classic you guys.
You know you got,
you got the shit end of the stick on
this thing and somehow you figured out a
way to drag us in there.
I'll tell you right now,
I'm staying in north of that fucking
sheet and when that guy comes in and goes,
hey, you want to hook up
your own cable? No I don't.
That's what the fuck I'm paying you for.
I don't want you to be below the,
the blanket below deck.
You don't need to be full
on that performance problems
for the next three months.
Cause I keep picturing my kid's
head coming Outta your twat. No,
I'm not doing this.
I shouldn't be in there.
My fucking in mash you
that after you said,
after you watch the movie,
you leaned over to me and he said,
I understand now why the guy
is an heir. You did? Yeah.
They get yelled at. No,
that's not what it was.
It was to provide comfort. You're
killing my fucking image here. Okay.
Don't stop showing your image.
Fuck urea image. No. So I'm
gonna. I want to be, yeah,
going to be a sober dead,
but on the road hobo time ripping it up.
Oh, it's just like every other
comic out there. You fucking heck.
I told you my last podcast.
I was going for a Boston accent word and
I realized that I was going to get in
trouble if I set it so that I had to
switch the concert. I was like, oh,
I'll talk to you. Liddy
Oh fuck yeah. Cool.
Fucking bed merely looks at me. He's
like, quants. I was like, it's a new day.
I'm going to get in trouble. If I say
to me, I don't mean anything by it,
so yeah.
Anyways,
don't end up like Kanye and never
everybody be mad at you. Oh,
he's going to be fine.
He knows what the fuck he's doing.
He was yelling. I mean, it'd
be honest with you, I don't
understand shows. Anyways,
there's no band.
Everybody's standing with their cell
phones on and there's somebody a wrapping
and then they're just sticking them.
I it's, it's, it's for young kids.
They love it and I'm not
going to go. They're like,
hey, you think this is music?
I'm not going to be that guy I got right.
Stay away from them.
I'm going to go see Casablanca in
the rain with a bunch of old people.
By the way, Nia. Yes. Did you
see during the break, those
old people trying to walk?
Holy fucking shit.
I cannot stress stretching and getting a
massage if you can afford to do it once
a month. Oh Jeez. That was
a hunched over beeble yeah.
A lot of people roughly my fucking
age too. Haven't limps and shit.
Like what the fuck did you
guys do? You know, look,
some of them probably fight a fucking war.
Who's kidding who?
But I'm just saying generally speaking,
you know what I mean?
I know maybe we should give them a rank.
So they didn't all fight a fucking war,
you know what I mean? They weren't all
on the front lines is what I'm saying.
A lot of those people peeling potatoes
and they're still fucking limp,
but that makes no sense.
All right, let me, um,
let me read a little bit of advertising.
Doesn't this peeling potatoes there?
Um, all right. Blue Apron,
everybody. You know, Neil,
I don't know if you to realize this,
but not all ingredients are created equal.
What Donald Trump's going
to become president.
This is what copy is gonna look like now.
Fresh, high quality white ingredients.
Does it make make a real difference?
So it's important to know where
your food comes. Um, all right. Uh,
affordable for less than
$10 per person per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with proportion ingredients to make
delicious home cooked meals.
Choose from a variety of new recipes each
week or let blue aprons culinary team
surprise you. Recipes are not repeated
within a year, so you'll never get bored.
It's flexible.
You can customize your recipes each
week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options
so you can choose the one that fits your
needs and there's no weekly commitment.
Sealy get deliveries when you want them.
Each meal comes with a step by step,
easy to follow recipe card and pre portion
of Greens and could be guaranteed in
40 minutes or less.
A blue aprons freshness guarantees,
promises that every ingredient in your
delivery arrives ready to cook or they'll
make it right.
Check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping. Big by going
to blue apron.com/. Burn.
You'll love how good it feels and tastes
to create incredible home cooked meals
with blue apron. So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook. Ah,
here we go. Everybody dope.
Dope me undies, Mia.
Andy's no more sweaty nuts.
Badu to two.
No more sweaty berries and switch it
up right when I started to take to me
undies. BMDS no more sweaty
berries, but all toto me, Andy's me,
Andy, you've fallen off a fucking
fairy. You go into the water,
your balls are still dry. Along
comes a sting. Ray puts out your eye.
You could have died like
the crocodile hunter.
I bet he wasn't wearing me undies
when he got stabbed there. Sorry.
Sorry. Australia. Me, undies.
Picture a world we're putting on a new
pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a better
day. Think about it. Underwear.
It's the first thing you put on
in the last thing you'd take off.
Unless you're fucking
weird. All right. No.
You know what? You have a
G. I can say that. You know,
what have you really have to just
take a shit you just fucking like,
you have to shit so bad. You bypass on
doing your belt and undoing your pants.
He just fucking, you know, you give you,
you give yourself the old right there,
Fred Yanking it all down. You
know, that's not true. Most,
most people when they get arrested,
only thing they have on, you know,
that's not true.
You just don't have a shirt.
There has been times where you just
have on a tee shirt, isn't it? Anyways,
why would you settle for anything less
than the best feeling underwear on the
planet? Well, because maybe you
have different priorities. I Dunno.
Please include the following points
during your read. Well, if you write it,
I'm going to fucking read it.
Um,
Yonnie's focuses solely on producing the
most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced.
My friends at me,
and he sent me a few pairs a while back
and now I can't imagine wearing anything
else.
It really makes each day that much better.
Stop putting words in my fucking
mouth. Yeah, they're comfortable,
but a few of them were way too
fucking, uh, a little racy for me.
You know what I mean?
The Greg Louganis cuts there are for
the price of two cocktails me undies,
we'll deliver you a new
pair of favor and underwear,
right to your right to your doorstep.
Better Day, guaranteed you Trey mine.
If you then, and not the most comfortable,
best feeling undies you've ever had,
and they'll refund you and let
you keep your first pair for free.
Included in the prices, the
sweet touch of modal, modal,
a special fabric made of the best in
class raw materials that are evidentaly,
scientifically proven to be
three times softer than cotton.
These Uber Cozy undies are
sold exclusively on the
[inaudible] website where
you'll enjoy free shipping.
And in us and Canada,
everybody else can go fuck themselves.
And for a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets
20% off their first order.
But you have to go to our special URL URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar with me
undies. It's a better day, guaranteed.
You have nothing to lose.
So don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr
right now for 20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash bar
all right. How many have we got left?
Uh, all right, we've got two quick ones
left. Can you hang in there? All right.
Simply safe, everybody.
It's, it's the safe place.
You're making this not a safe place.
I'm going to wear a safety pit.
Simply safe.
Ever find yourself almost all
the way to work. Or maybe you're,
you're out with your family and friends
and you get that nagging feeling.
Did I close the window?
Did I lock that door?
Why did I fuck the maid?
Lie?
Did I fuck the made the kids go
through look like me? Um, sorry.
It's a Schwartzenegger reference.
You just don't know.
It can drive you nuts there.
Well,
you don't have to worry about it when
you simply safe home security. Well,
if you left the fucking window open,
you can't set the, well, I get it.
You can't set the alarm.
Okay.
It's a nice extra layer of protection
to now simply safe is there.
Simply safe has an arsenal of fence.
There's to protect your entire family,
your entire home, and keep
your family safe. Simply save.
Got Rid of everything that makes most
to secure a home security, such a pain.
There's no longterm contracts,
no hidden fees. They won't Gouge.
It's 1499 a month.
That's three times less than one other
companies charge and about $150 less than
I paid for a fucking movie ticket today.
And here's some big news.
Simply safe has just released its brand
new high definition security camera.
This camera is different.
You know what's great about that?
You can actually see the criminals
face. You know, instead of having an,
I'll pixelate it out,
you can actually look and be like,
is that my neighbor?
This camera's different.
It connects directly to your security
system and sense your sense to it,
to your smartphone, a smartphone video.
The second something happens at your home,
what the fuck?
That's crazy.
You can see everything that's going on so
you don't have to wonder anymore to do.
That means you're going to be
out at the restaurant, right?
And you just gotta be eating.
And all of a sudden some random customer
to be like, Dude, what the fuck? Right.
Freaking out. Like instead of just calling
the cops, I don't know what you do.
Checkout simply safe's new camera
today. I'll do that. We'll be sickening.
You don't, you seem grabbing like your
favorite fucking shit out of the house.
Just go to simply safe burg.com right now.
That simply safe bird.com simply
save bird.com and filing Nia.
Come on in.
MVMT watches pronounced movement was
founded on the belief that style shouldn't
break the bank. Yeah, you should listen
to this. Yeah. What they just said.
This means you spend too much fucking
money. You know exactly what it means.
So don't play dumb with me.
What are you calling me?
And he had to attack me.
I that was like what?
You can create the advertising thing. I
was going to come back when you're a ton.
Yeah.
And I suddenly show me.
I suddenly gave you shit and then you
pull the emergency brake and down here we
are. Everybody knows. Once again,
style shouldn't break the bank.
The watchmaker's goal is to change the
way consumers think about fashioning by
offering high quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices.
Nia,
I hear you.
With over 500,000 watches
sold to customers in 160
countries around the world,
movement watches has just
solidified itself as the
world's fastest growing watch
company movement watches start at just $95
at a department store.
You're looking at four to 500 bucks.
Nia movement figured out by sell.
By selling online,
they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup,
providing the best possible price classic
to the quality construction styled
minimalism. Over 500,000 watches
sold in over 160 countries.
Get 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to movement
watches.com/bird that's
MVMT watches.com/spur.
This watch has a really clean
design. Seriously, okay. Um,
you're going to get a lot of
compliments if you wear this watch.
Now is the time to step up your game.
Go to Mvmt,
watches.com/burr join the movement.
All right. You want to answer
a few questions before we
get the fuck Outta here?
Sure.
Before we get the fuck outta here.
Uh, what's the score to the game? Yeah.
Right. That watch that I have, by the way,
I didn't say you did.
He just taken the bait and the,
I'm just breaking your fucking
ovaries over there. Um,
what does the score to the fucking game?
I'll just show them the highlights.
All right. Hey there,
Billy clairvoyant. Uh,
you probably didn't notice this because
I doubt you'll you listen back to your
own podcast,
but there have been throwback parallels.
I actually listened to my podcast is I
upload them. I just listening to them,
you know, I don't know why I do. He
loves the sound of his own voice.
Um, that's not true. I've learned to love
it when you first hear your own voice,
you don't like it.
Now I can't live without it.
I walk around with headphones in my
house just listening to my own podcast.
When Andrew cuts together the clips, he
uses the same date from eight years ago.
Last Thursday was from November
17th, 2008. Oh, he told me
he does it. That's cool.
He said in that episode you made a
reference to cash cab, which was hosting,
which was hosted by your guests this week,
Ben Bailey, also a couple of weeks ago.
When you first mentioned
watching Westworld,
the throwback clip had you mentioned
the original Westworld once again,
eight years ago to the, to
the day. Yeah, that back then.
That's what I wanted to buy the rights
to it until I realized it was zillions of
dollars. And I was like, oh, forget it by,
by everybody and all. I had in my
whole representation all excited. Like,
is he going to do something like this? We
can get a piece of this. And I was like,
oh, that's too much money. Um, he said,
I'll be on the lookout for more of
these and hopes to exploit your magic.
Love you love Nia. Well, that's
all. I love you too, boo.
That's all due to, um, what's his
face? Uh, Andrew. Andrew, like,
I think he tries to find like the
parallel, so that's his homework,
not mine. All right. Thanksgiving
recipe a there Billy White meat
and I liked it. Billy White
Paper, the other white meat,
the other white meat a
there, Billy White meat. Uh,
what are you going to
teach us to cook this year?
If I don't get another cooking video?
Like the pie crust masterpiece.
I'm boycotting the season.
I'm the single one of my siblings.
And last year I showed up with a Pi and
waited until everyone was done to let
them know I made it.
Then I showed them your Wii video and
we had some full fully belly last full,
I think full belly laughs is what you
want to say. Uh, don't let me make a,
don't let me make,
let my family down.
Don't let me let my family
down by letting me down. Okay.
Thanks for all the free labs. Um,
hearing you get through that. So I know
my eyes are always 10 words ahead
of what I can fucking remember.
I think that's what happens.
So maybe I'm just dumb. Um,
it's going to be sad when our
kids, a better reader than
me. Fucking six months in
her baby's going to teach you how to read.
It's going to read you a book.
And Maya, I, whenever I've read
to like my nieces and nephews,
like there's a point when they stopped
looking at the book and they just turn
around and look at me and then it's like
more pressure at him and I'm literally
reading like the rabbit
goes, hop, hop, hop, hop.
It doesn't go hop. It
hops. A cow goes moo.
And maybe that helps you out
there. Fucking old and bald. Um,
well I feel like last year,
like making a pie crust,
it was like a real fucking
skill that I had. Like,
I don't know what else to show you
guys, how to make, um, you know,
if Nia lets me get this fucking
griddle that I want to get, Oh my God,
this great old, oh my God, this fucking
griddle. It's like you love when I Cook,
but you don't want to be, you don't
want to, you know what I mean?
It's like you like your freedom,
but you don't want to see how it happens.
You're the same way with food. You know
touchdown fucking Redskins. God dammit,
because I don't know what,
what are you trying to do here?
You're trying to get like every fucking
invention that has to do with cooking or
grilling or smoking or frying.
You want to buy it and it's just like,
where are we going to put all this shit?
Okay,
let's list all the shit that I've bought.
I'm not saying that you bought it all.
I'm saying that you want to buy it at all.
Why? I do want to buy it all
and why haven't I bought it all?
Because there's no room for it.
Oh, and who determined that?
I mean, oh, another Ms Dexter point.
Who determined that Nia, I you decided
that? I thought it was a mutual. Yep.
Wasn't all right.
I had a buddy of mine was going to hook
me up with this smoke up pellet smoker,
you said? No. Okay.
Well because he tried to act like
he told me it was a size of a,
of a typewriter and then we'll be a solid
and when he actually showed it to me,
he was like, come here, let me show you.
Let me show you what it looks like
and then I looked at it and I'm like,
and what universe is this? The size of a
typewriter? It's the size of her. I said,
it's a sewing, like a sewing
machine. He goes, oh yeah, yeah.
It's more like a sewing machine. I'm
like, a sewing machine is on a typewriter.
Okay,
tell you something there.
That's why guys are great.
That's why I love that dude
forever because you know
we do that for each other.
I don't know if women do. I want to
speak for you guys, but guys do that
for each other. It was a
site. It's the size of a wall.
You need a kitchen the size of his
kitchen in order to do all the things that
you want to do.
Yeah, portable thing. It's on
fucking wheels. It's in the back,
but we got like three fucking tables in
the backyard and I can't get rid of any
of those tables for the
fucking potato salad. You know,
every piece of furniture I put in the
backyard has a function and we have used
it in that function. That doesn't make
any sense, but you could also mean no,
you're,
what you're doing is you've become
the dictator or the fucking backyard.
You're the woman. I own the
backyard. I own the fucking garage.
If we had a basement, that's my shit. You
can have the rest of the fund can house.
All right, so what is saying? I'm
saying I'm getting that griddle.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right. Well, I have
Jesus Christ. Yeah,
you're going to hear him say that until
I fucking make you a nice fucking steak
and cheese or make some hash browns
or make a grand slam breakfast gains.
You've been making all of
those things without the grid
because it guy, right? So,
exactly. So what do you need all this
other stuff for if you're so talented?
Because just imagine how good it would
taste if I actually had a fucking griddle,
even though it's fucking
stoves that have a griddle.
If the thing sucks because it's,
it's one heat source, so you can't,
you can't have difference. He can't move
it around. You can't play with your heat.
It sucks. It's like this
is the temperature. It's
a pain in the fucking ass.
It's one thing if you've got a pot or
a pan, you can take it on the heat,
take it off,
but when you're on your fucking Gretel,
you know you want one on one off
and maybe one a little bit on.
Why don't you just get one of those old
little electric grills at the little,
the little way a freshman in college.
Once you can put on your counter, well,
when you divorce me. Oh, that's too
sad to say. If you ever do that.
Do you ever do that?
And I'll do everything that it can be
as a grown fucking man to buy divorcee
kitchen products. Fuck. Are
you talking about divorce?
I'll go to Mcdonald's and grab some extra
packets of ketchup for in the future
when I need more ketchup. I've done all
that. Nia, I've used shares for tables,
ate pasta all fucking day, had pancakes.
I've done all that. I've done this.
We know. Yeah. Yeah. Yo, you sick of my
self made man. Shit, that annoys you,
doesn't it?
I would eat spaghetti with prego and,
and the bread because we fill me
up and it will last me all night,
do all my spots and I would eat pancakes
because it kept me the most full like
cement. And you know how I'm doing
that for the fucking people out there.
Women included.
Go on to be one to fucking make something
happen and food's a big thing cause
you got a fucking habit every day. She
got to have that shit that fills you up.
Right? Listen, don't let this little ray
of Sunshine fucking rain on your parade.
Okay. I'm here for all you
guys. I'm the positive guy.
I'm the motivational speaker.
Hey,
speaking of motivation of what the
fuck's going on with the P90x guy,
do you become a Vegan or something? Well
first of all, he's not too P90x anymore.
He's got a dick thing late night.
Yeah. Yeah. But now Tony Horton,
he's looking a little like,
he's not doing his pull ups anymore.
He's getting older. He's looking like, um,
I dunno. He's looking
all veggie. Hmm. Anyways,
so I don't know what I'm going
to make this year. I told you.
Oh, you mean for the people? For
this guy. Yeah. Yeah. You want me to,
I'm not showing my family secret family
fucking recipe of the best stuffing
you're ever going to have admitted.
Most people stuffing fucking
sucks stuffing that bill.
Maggs oh my God.
It's so delicious and I've never had good,
that's the only stuffing I've ever
had that even like it. Me Too.
I don't ever like stuffing.
I don't roast.
It was wet and it already
has a bad aftertaste. Yeah,
this is nice and crispy and like buttery.
Oh, it's so good. Yeah. When you got,
you got that fucking barbecue the other
night. You didn't like the corn bread.
They put that weird ingredient in there.
Ah,
bumble you so and so. Read
another question. Dammit.
When the fuck did I
become such a packers fan?
This is certain old NFL teams I like.
I see like the giants.
Can you fucking believe that if the
what they did to my patriots twice, um,
one flew over the cuckoo's nest. All
right. Hey, they're all Billy bibbet.
Um, it's funny who's vivid?
It was a character in one
flew over the cuckoo's nest.
Oh Shit.
What's his face downstairs here and old
friend of mine has gone so far down the
rabbit hole of conspiracy theories that
he really can't even function in society
anymore. Oh, that's relatable.
Tell him to start telling jokes.
Ease.
He is unable to hold a conversation for
two minutes without going off on some
rambling horse shit about chem
trails, Freemasons, aliens,
and all of that crap.
Completely oblivious to the fact that
none of us are interested in hearing about
all that nonsense he reads on the
Internet. It used to be funny,
we were driving out west a few years
back and he pointed out at some lights
moving up in the sky and said, those
are the aliens that follow me around.
Oh, this sounds like a
mental issue, dude. I said,
what does that sign on the right said?
He said, airport next sex, exit it.
And I said, yeah, those are airplanes.
You check. Yes. And he said,
well, maybe some of
them. Wow. He goes, okay.
It's been over a decade of that
kind of Shit. And it's gotten way,
way worse because of this obsession
and the resulting paranoia.
He can't even hold down a menial job. And
all of his friends have abandoned ship.
He become addicted to painkillers. I
think he already had a mental issue, man.
Yeah,
of course.
Has Been in and out of rehab centers
in hospitals because of bizarre health
problems and is now bordering on
full blown schizophrenia. Well,
you don't get that from reading
conspiracy theory, sir. Yeah.
You really kind of did a fucking
thing right here with that question,
that whole thing in the beginning,
which is like a red herring.
It turns out he's got like serious
mental problems. What's a red herring?
It's just, it's just a
distraction. Exactly.
It's something that you think
is the cause of, you know,
I'm not explaining it right,
cause I'm tired, but oh,
I gotta use that excuse sometimes when I
use an expression that it can, oh Jesus,
my brain mush
Christ.
How many points does fucking Aaron
Rodgers got to put up? You know,
it's like Tom Brady,
same thing.
How many fucking points is you get a
score at the end. It's gonna, you know,
defense.
Um,
I want to respect his right to
believe what he wants to believe,
but in the end it has only caused him
to lead and increasingly miserable and
lonely life that will end in a tragedy
and a sparsely attended funeral unless
something changes soon.
So how the fuck do you bring someone
back from so far over the edge? Okay,
well he might be exaggerating a
little bit with maybe he's using,
schizophrenia is like a fucking filler
word. They're like, you know, this guy,
narcissists, guy's a sociopath, but sounds
like paranoid schizophrenia answers.
Exactly. Oh, Dr. Hill.
Or you're going to diagnose that on this
fucking fucking email. Unfortunately,
a member of my family who
went through this exact thing,
I do feel that I recognize it a little
bit. Yes. As a matter of fact, I do. Okay.
But do you feel like that you can make
that diagnosis as someone who is not a
doctor? No, of course not.
A comedian is not even a podcaster that
you can on a podcast done by a comedian
as not a doctor.
Diagnose this person that you've never
met based on this four paragraph email to
come in here. So I'm giving my
opinion. You're going to start a song.
You asked me to come here.
Are you annoyed that that lady
singing about all the ingredients,
you get annoyed when black shit goes
fucking mainstream and then white people
ruin it? Well, I got peas, greens,
tomatoes, potatoes. That she,
yeah,
that thing.
I swear to God if, if that's what my
whole week long run before everyone else.
That was my,
my church was like I would,
I would go every week if it was
only a half hour long. I still see,
I just can't get into the fucking,
I liked to sing and
part of black churches,
but even when the priest,
regardless of race,
when they get up there and they start
saying that this invisible guy gives a
shit about me, that's, I just, I tap
out. I just can't listen to it. Anyway,
he wants,
he teases tcis she hair that.
That's the second flat screen
downstair friend needs per chill stuff.
You're not going to be a, I like
Jola state. He's a very positive guy.
Well you know something,
he's been out there long enough that you'd
think if there was a scandal it would
come up. I know, right. Um, this,
your friend needs professional
help. This is beyond your, um,
this is beyond your pay grade.
Cheez its don't Shit on the guy.
He might have just been being funny
just because I'm not shitting on him.
I'm saying that you're,
his friend needs help and this is not
anything that he is qualified to do.
So because he listened.
Not much nicer way of saying the sanest
beyond your pay grade a buddy and she
get go pick up your
Broman keep sweeping up.
This is the job of people
with lab coats. Um, hold
on a second.
But what does he is he said like,
I respect his right to believe what he
wants to believe, but in the end that Dah,
Dah, Dah. Yeah. I don't, I don't even
think he necessarily maybe even believes,
believes that he's just
got, yeah, he's, yeah.
He's becoming into paying claims had
been in and out of rehab centers and
hospitals because of bizarre
health problems. Yeah.
He is now bordering on full
blown schizophrenia. Yeah.
I think you just gotta be there for them,
but maybe just check in on them and
say, Hey, are you taking your meds?
Are you going to see your doctor?
That type of thing. But sure.
I don't think you're going to be
able to like help him with this.
It's all on you. Is that what
I decided to, yeah. Yeah.
You know,
it's fucking cool as shit.
The Redskins still have a band and
they actually have a team song.
I think that's fucking cool.
It's a professional level.
For some reason that all went away. I
hope our baby doesn't get your add. Why?
It's worked great for me. It has it. Yeah.
Yeah, it has. Yeah.
I played drums for helicopter still jokes
add as far as a fucking great thing
to have. It's sucks with some shit,
but it's gets,
it sucks when you're in school and
you're going to do poorly in school and
everyone's going to say you're fucking
dumb, but when you get out in the world,
man,
it's fucking tremendous.
It's tremendous.
I know I run around all
day long having very,
so you don't have it like severely though.
You are able to fucking, you just get,
you know, even get the lab
glasses on tonight though.
Just fucking diagnosed and everything.
How do you know what I have at is
remember when we tried to do that add
questionnaire and you couldn't
even pay attention long enough
to answer the question you have a part of
that was because I was annoyed with it.
You want to revisit that real quick? Do
an Oldie but goodie. All Right, Bill,
my kid is 14 years old, 14 years old
and he wants a drone for Christmas.
The drone market is huge with
kids these days. When I was a kid,
we want it to fly something
for the sake of flying it.
Now they all have cameras attached to
them and they hover in a real creepy way.
He's not a punk, so he won't
flip out if he doesn't get one.
His friends have them. So it's not
like he, he had never used one.
If I did get him one and he's not the
type of kid to fly it up to someone's
window.
So that's not the concern.
I'm coming from a place like if I
didn't want him to get an earring,
uh, more of, don't be that kid. I might be
overreacting, but that's just something.
But there's just something about
drones. What do you think, uh,
congrats on the condition.
Uh, thank you. Um,
I would say, uh, I agree with you. No
drowns, no drones with the cameras.
That's too much to shoot the
shit I would have fucking done.
I would have the hottest
chick in the neighborhood.
I would have had it out there hovering,
hovering near a bathroom.
Yay.
If he's not, then his friends are going
to, his friends are going to be like,
let's just take it over here and just see,
and this is a thing,
you know,
that the person watching is jerking
off if it immediately crashes.
So kids are really using drone like that.
There are they is that the hot gift?
This Christmas is a drone
for a teenager. I mean it's,
it's an amazing fucking thing.
It really is.
I mean,
I can't imagine like just flying
over a neighborhood to see what your
neighborhood looks like from the air or
your house. All of that would be cool.
But the, the, the possibilities,
the shit that she could do
with those things, uh, in a,
with the juvenile brain, I
don't know. I would be nervous.
One of the best things my parents did
was they never let us play video games.
They never let us play it. They
just, you're not getting that.
It's going to fuck with the schoolwork.
You know,
it's funny as I still fucked up in school,
but the great thing is is I'm
not a fucking 48 year old gamer.
You know like I just think that's,
that's really like a
I, I, you know,
I kind of judges that shit like
after a while like like what do you,
what are you doing? You know what I
mean? Which you want to go outside.
Like the amount of time that people spend.
You could learn a language,
you learn how to play an instrument is
I'm literally doing whatever you get
delta is.
You could go out and do the things that
I find interesting the fuck if you're
into video games,
go ahead and play it.
But I'm glad that I didn't cause I wasted
enough time watching fucking sports.
I can't imagine because I told you I've,
I've always said I tapped out
after grand theft auto three.
It literally took over my life.
I'm so sick of this fucking commercial
where they showed the Ford F-150 with the
aluminum bed and it has,
it doesn't have any bed liner and they
dropped the fucking toolbox into it and
then they showed the Chevy with the steel
one. This is such bullshit advertising.
What it's really is,
is I bet the Ford gets better gas mileage
because it has a lighter bed and then
all you do is just put that to the same
rubber guard that comes in all pickup
trucks.
What kind of a fucking asshole buys a
pickup truck and you don't have the bed
liner? The Fuck Outta here. Fuck Chevy.
Even though I like this Silverado.
All right. Thanksgiving
debacle. Oh, Billy Turkey legs.
Don't get your kid a drone if you don't
want them to have the drone. You're the,
you're the parent. All right. Um,
it wasn't another add moment
that I leave it there.
I'm going a little debacle with
lady
about Thanksgiving.
I want my girl to come to my thanksgiving,
but it starts like only
an hour before hers.
I'm going a little bit of a dip
out for my lady about Thanksgiving.
I want my girl to come to my thanksgiving,
but it starts only an hour before hers,
but they're in the same time town.
Mind you, mine's at my aunt's
house in hers. Is that her parents?
Mine starts at 12 hers starts at one
30 I wanted her to come to mind for a
little bit before hers,
but she's not having it because
she's got to help her mom cook. Well,
this is easy.
So you just say you'll be over there
at fucking one 30 and you just going to
make an appearance, which you can make
it nutsy your family on Thanksgiving.
He said, on one hand, I'm super
salty and want to be a huge in,
want to make a huge deal
about this because I really
want her there and I think
she's being selfish,
but on the other hand,
I understand she's got to
help her mom cook and stuff.
At least that's her excuse.
I know she loves her family,
but it really pisses me off because
she's never been to my family shit.
But I've got gone.
I've gone to plenty of hers.
Hers offense is that she's never made me
miss any of my family gatherings to go
to hers. But my family is a bunch
of nut jobs and you get the point,
uh, old Billy burnt Dick. I
could use some words of wisdom.
I am a huge fan. Thanks. And Go fuck
yourself. Happy holidays. Huge Fan. Well,
I mean this is all you're doing
so you can undo all of this.
All right.
Yeah.
You know, you just gotta put your foot
down. Just say, listen, I respect,
I understand you've got to help
you mother cook. But I, you know,
I want to see my aunt, my family on
Thanksgiving, so I will go over there.
I'll be there over the for an hour.
All right.
And then I'll be over here at one 30
in time to eat and if she has a problem
with that, um, just ask her why
do you have a problem with that?
This is perfect. I, I'll, I'll, you
don't have, you don't have to come,
you don't have to come to, to, uh,
my family of nut jobs as you say.
And uh,
yeah,
she's trying to get out of going to your
families is what I'm wondering because
most people,
I feel like in the situation,
you just split it up so she's
got to go help her family cook.
Okay.
You could go over there with
her while they're doing that.
Talk to the dad of the brothers,
whatever.
I don't know if they're going to be
cooking or whatever. Spend that time,
have the meal and then the
two of you then go to your,
your family's house for dessert and like
coffee and a movie or a game night or
whatever.
Yeah.
There's his starts early. It starts at 12
they're starts at one 30 so I'm saying,
I just, I tell, listen, you go
over your mom's house, you cook.
I'm going over my aunts from 12 to one
I'll be back at one 30 show up like,
and then you show up at like one 40
you know what?
I'm going to spend like an hour though.
That's nothing
you cause you'd like the food isn't
going on the table right at swell.
Everyone's going to like saunter and
around 1230 1245 sit down then eat.
I would take it,
it's going to be there.
This is what I would do. I would say this
deal, I'm going to there for an hour,
then I'm gonna go to one 30. Right?
One 30, I'll be at your place,
but next year we're going to my families.
This isn't even about like,
I'm not going to like never see my
family on Thanksgiving again. Right.
I would never do that to you.
Are you saying I can't see my family
anymore on Thanksgiving? You just do that.
Just
go, yeah, go to his
families and just say, Hey,
text me when you guys are about to like
sit down because she's going to cook and
do all this other stuff.
So it was like,
text me when you guys
are about to sit down.
I'll let you know where I'm at
with my dinner and then I'll just
come over there.
And that's what he need to do is say it
totally calmly do not trasher do not,
do not say anything insulting about
her family. Do not let her. Uh,
and then when you stay calm,
if she does that thing where she
then tries to bait you into a fight,
do not take the bait.
Just ask her why she's reacting
that way or just stay calm.
Stay on target star wars. Right. You just,
you just make your points and that's it.
Yeah, that sounds reasonable.
Well there you go.
So you like how great the movie was
Casablanca and it was really nice.
I finally understood the fucking movie.
I always got confused.
I understood the love story, but I,
I didn't quite understand, you know,
unoccupied France and the talking
and like Nazi Germany and shit.
It's just like the taking over
your country and it's just like,
I guess they hadn't there.
Their power hadn't
gotten to that point cause it
was like Italian soldiers there.
There was German soldiers and there was
fucking these, these German Nazi guys.
I don't know.
I'll have to watch it again.
I'd maybe read a little
bit of fucking history,
but I actually understood the love
story this time. It was fucking great.
How beautiful is that woman
too, Huh? Yeah, she's beautiful.
She was like modern day. Beautiful too.
A lot of them back then or back then.
Beautiful. You know what I
mean? Like, Hey, what'd he say?
They're fucking Ellis
island. She's a classic. Ah,
ah, there she goes. There you go.
Sleep and like a damn dog lately
because of your condition,
because the main condition,
very tired.
I think you'd be in a
jerk about it personally.
They think you're being a jerk about
it. I'm not. Why is my fucking leg hurt?
Oh my God. I'm going to end like those
fucking people in the orchestra pit. Just,
we'll fucking Lisi that one guy
was like 55 just sitting there.
He looked like he just
fell off a motorcycle.
Um, anyways. Well I'm glad you had a
good time. I hope you enjoy it because a,
I'm watching all the rest of the football
Sundays from here on out is they empty
the liquor cabinet. So is that our last
Sunday out? Is that what you're saying?
Until, and I would like to do that.
I've been asked and I've been, uh,
looking up museums and
shit on the download,
trying to understand Armoury I never
understood it. I find that I, I like,
uh, uh, I forget what period is,
it's the van Gogh when the period out
to van Gogh. I liked that shit. Okay,
that's cool. I liked that. The abstract.
I'm starting to understand that. Well,
you don't need lines. You have colors
to suggest moods. It's like, all right,
let's get shit.
I know it looks like a five year old.
It's always going to look
like a five year old. Did it?
What do you like modern art do you think?
Or do you like the more old classic stuff?
Uh,
like the van Gogh versus the Jeff
Koons. I don't know who, Jeff Koons.
Andy Warhol. Andy Warhol was the
original hipster. His brutally,
brutally fucking overrated. Ooh.
Heartache and was not a nice person.
And what about basket? Yeah. Did
you like basket? I like basket. It's not
the dude looks like saving and Glover,
but he painted
safe young Glover.
Wow. Oh my God. I haven't heard
that name in awhile. Uh, yes.
He's sorta like the weekend
before he cut his hair,
he was doing like an homage
to basket. Yeah. Yes. That's,
that's the John Michel Basquiat. That's
the most modern person I listened to.
Yeah. To the point I preordered
his next album. I know, I love it.
I got it. I got the first two
songs. I want to hear it. Oh,
he said listen to it after this.
Absolutely.
As I fall asleep because of my condition.
How far are we talking about my condition?
Not that much. Right. What do you mean?
Like we're not going to get into all
like all the specifics. No we're not.
I'm just, something's got the sacks and
all that pictures. No, none of that shit.
It's just like the kitchen.
You just get to know it got redone.
Just know that after I share enough,
there's too many fucking Weirdos
on the fucking Internet. I don't,
I do not understand people that post
pictures of their children, you know,
because you get excited because there's
so going home address right above your
fucking head for them,
for the family photo.
Cause they're so cute and you just
want to like show off, you know.
But I definitely understand
why we will not be doing that.
All right.
This is probably a conversation that
should have happened off of the podcast.
All right, you fucking coolant bill.
What the fuck did I do to my leg?
I just laid down and I feel
like I hyper extended my,
who is the
comedian?
What's his name? You always
bring him up, Richard Kind? No.
Uh, oh. Robert Klein. Robbery Gla.
Robert Klein. I can't stop my look.
Very good. Look at you. See I wear, I
wear saving Glover. Then you hit me back.
White style little Robert Klein. All
right, that's the podcast for this week.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Have a wonderful Thanksgiving and I will
be checking in on you on Thanksgiving.
No, you will not. You say,
well no, you will not. Listen,
we're going to eat at one 30 I'm going
to do a podcast at 12 at my parents'
house. Take. You can, you
can take Thanksgiving off.
People understand Nia,
I believe you are.
People said money never sleeps right here.
24 seven. What are some of the
stupid shit they asleep? We grind.
Yeah. I'll let dumb shit like,
like Bill Gates isn't doing that.
You're going to do a podcast
on thanksgiving. What
is wrong with you? Well,
maybe you'll do it the day
before thanksgiving. That's
a big pet peeve of mine.
When performers or talk about how
fucking hard they work, you know,
and they take those pictures
of them where they lived,
they got their head down like
they're fucking exhausted, you know,
and then he just said leads to
these fucking and posed compliments.
You know that people would stop.
I feel like I'm just beginning.
But that essentially what you're doing,
if you're going to be working on
thanksgiving, no, nothing. No,
that was a really weak way to try
to manipulate it back and the,
I'm going to do it. So if you just,
you want to have the argument now,
cause I'm gonna do it. I'm too
tired. There you go. Go to sleep.
Seriously, you're putting on
a lot of weight and Oh my God,
I'm not attracted to you right now.
I just don't understand what it is.
That's not true. Don't say that. Yeah,
he just told me I look beautiful.
I do look through. You still look great.
You're all fucking baby in my belly.
You're all belly. So
anyways, all right. I'm uh,
I dunno.
I'm going to figure out how to make a
fucking pan into a griddle and make myself
something because I'm an adult and I,
I can't fucking have a griddle.
I'm sure you'll figure it out.
No, I'm getting that grill.
I'm getting rid of those
fucking tables out there.
There's too many fucking tables. Huh?
What do we have in the last supper?
Is Jesus coming back right in our back
fucking yard and that longwinded do,
she's going to sit there and [inaudible].
Good to do for you.
I did the trashy Norman. Yes.
He trash in Jesus. Jesus.
Is that, is that what county he
goes by? Yes. Easy. Hey radio.
Fuck you.
Um,
I want to get,
I'm going to get that big.
I would just yelling
at a fucking what did,
what would you call that when his
radio form of communication. Yeah.
Yell at a form of communication and
then cancel a show at the fucking,
he has to be a magic Johnson's
house. Fuck you. A Internet.
You Internet on a string,
but you ham radio.
We get it. Kevin Hart's
funny. But, so, uh,
I was a kid I saw in fucking
the new def jam, first of all,
Tony Rock flushing it as a host.
Tony rocks a fucking star by the way.
I remember years ago when he had a sketch
show my next to the guy fucking pop on
it. He pops on TV. Robert, uh, I forget
his last name. You tweet or not? Tony?
Not Tony Roberts. Tony
Roberts. I have no, no, no.
The name of the comic that you liked,
you tweeted about him,
his name is Robert something. Oh
yeah, he was fucking hilarious.
Fucking hilarious and didn't give a shit
if the crowd liked him. He had that,
the fucking Luther Vandross
joke. Oh my God. Yeah. I
don't want to ruin it, but uh,
yeah,
just definitely check that out.
Cause if that's how funny that shows is
that that show was back in a, in a, uh,
a big way and it was great to see
Tony rocket and that Gig. You know,
definitely deserving ending on a positive
note. That's right. Go fuck yourselves.
I will talk to you on Thanksgiving
and that's stopping you hear in the
background.
We'll be near
on approvingly supposedly making
stuffing. All right, go fuck yourselves.
Have a great week. Great short week.
All right, and off to Wednesday night,
the greatest fucking night ever.
If you're a young man, right? You go
back to your hometown. What's his face?
The thrill ride. The thrill ride did a
great rant on that. Who? The trail ride?
The one man fucking, oh yeah,
that guy. We'd that guy.
That guy should be in the WWE. He's one
of the best people on the fucking mic.
I forgot about him. Yeah,
he fucking said that.
That's the night you go
back and all the women,
you know you went to high school with
that she would more afraid to talk to and
now you come back.
You got your little man mustache.
You make something happened the night
before Thanksgiving for Thanksgiving.
That's right.
Okay.
I love Thanksgiving. You. I
love bud Thanksgiving and she,
we just rub it in the fucking
English England's face, you know,
take that. Right. But no,
there's a lot of people in this country
that think it has to do something with
our independence with England.
I nothing to do with that.
Well that's one of my favorite things to
do is I say that to fucking London ears
and shit. All fucking one. I
forgot to bring up. There's a,
I got to do another benefit.
Uh, speaking of that, um,
a buddy of mine who did stand up when I
started out and then moved on to writing,
uh,
Pete coming such a great guy
unfortunately passed away.
Uh, Oh God, a couple of weeks
ago. It was an absolute shock.
He's like a fucking year older than
me, was in great health and just, uh,
had a heart attack unfortunately.
So we're going to be doing a benefit
at the laugh factory on December six
tickets will be going on sale soon.
I should probably know by a thanksgiving.
But uh, he's got two beautiful
twin boys, the only 10 years old.
And um, the great thing is
going to be all so great.
Was Jamie Masada put his name
up on the, uh, the marquee.
I'll never forget that. He did that. That
was such a great thing that he did that.
Cause Pete hasn't done stand
up in a number of years.
It was great that Jamie remembered
him. He's a great guide. Jamie Masada,
he remembered them. He put
his name up there. And uh,
so there's a bunch of
Boston guys I haven't seen.
We're all going to be on
the same fucking show. Um,
and I'm trying to think like the last
time we all worked together like that,
it was probably the fucking
cow loon about 20 years ago.
So it's going to be a good reunion.
We're all gonna be telling great
stories about, uh, p. And so, um, yeah,
it's going to be December six,
and I'll get you guys that link as
soon as I get it. If you're in town,
you'd like to have a laugh, uh, to
great cause. All right. That's it.
They have Fuckos have a nice thanksgiving.